[Music]
go ahead it's the thing I was just
saying before we went live is since I
last hung out with you I just noticed a
little bit seemingly more heaviness
almost like life's weighing you down a
little more and wondered if that was
true and and how it is to hear it from
me yeah it's an interesting that you
notice that and I wonder what exactly is
happening and it takes a good amount of
reflection to be able to dig deep and
try and figure this stuff out what is it
about about me that sends off the heavy
mists
I really like what I saw you do they're
like seem like the questions quite a
deep one or like wool and it seemed like
you just let us know that I'm willing to
explore this but yeah could you maybe
give me another question
yeah openness totally to dig deeper and
I'm glad that give me gay give me that
what is it about this heaviness well I
can say for me like I feel this like
fiery sensation now in my belly and I
think it's personal excite there was
something that where I was I just relate
with your kind of enthusiasm about life
to have these conversations and then I
think my I've been weighed down a lot
like I can see see the projection of
like I've faced a lot harder challenges
since the last time we talked
and so I I almost like like we can sniff
one of our own that's interesting I like
that a lot because it's been about a
year since our first show together yeah
and now you're bringing on Sean with you
to unpack a little bit about what we're
doing right now and we have
interestingly in a year both been
growing a lot and and potentially facing
these adversities that can sometimes we
like to think of them as things to
overcome to find our greatest treasures
on the other side of them but it's what
I'd like to say like what maybe what I'm
doing now is say I'm like being here
with you like I know the context were in
I'm like already imagining the audience
but the audience might notice like I'm
talking almost about my talking mm-hmm
so what I'm doing is I'm using my
to be aware of what's already happening
in me and rather than try to go into
like content to make it work I'm just
like revealing where I am mm-hmm yeah
that's good way to put it and it seems
like we discovered the practice circling
where we learnt to do this that when you
do that you just gain all this extra
information and actually more connection
with people so it's like you're
developing your self-awareness and at
the set which is already cool but then
you're also feeling closer and like your
relationships get like more meaningful
so it's like win-win okay so let's see
if we can break this down so we maybe
feel an urge frequently to just provide
content to fill this space between
relationships yeah and maybe instead of
having filling the urge to fill the
space we instead just say how we're
feeling talk about our awareness and how
after doing 400 of these it is
interesting to realize what that
actually means and what it's like
sitting here with different people and
it's like looking at the landscape as
you go on the journey instead of just
going on the journey so it's good to
take in the landscape and I think maybe
what you just said could even be
something to reflect on in the
conversations that we have onset is just
to say you know oh how does that make
you feel I'm just like slowing down with
that yeah and it looks like you're like
you kind of even now like you go in like
you you're such a personable like
charismatic like you've done 400 of
these you know what it's like oh yeah
it's like that feels natural but then we
like getting these territories what
we're like we're now we're navigating
our relationship like we're we're
looking for something that we share but
it's vulnerable and what I think what
happens in me is I'm like if I kind of
keep leaning into this
you know what what is it like for you to
have this this heaviness and what maybe
we don't talk about what's happened but
like now we're in it I don't know what's
gonna happen
mm-hm and so I don't have any control
and that's where like the connection
gets built as I in that aliveness so it
gets deepened but it's it's really scary
because like I don't know where we're
gonna go
mm-hmm maybe now I redirect back and ask
what what is it about that the heaviness
that you also feel over the last year
that's a good question what can I say
like because I've just met you and like
I actually felt quite touched meeting
you it's not often I meet someone just
like in the first contact like bring so
much warmth so that was like well and
then and you've actually you've actually
stayed like that we've only been
together half an hour so that feels like
yeah that I really noticed that but then
there is something where I'm also like
feel like I can feel your shop or I can
feel your directedness you you might I
actually like it yeah you you and it can
feel like that's like the warmth they
say relaxing and like well that's like I
can I feel open in the directedness it's
like yeah that's intense
the the first impressions that we have
for one another are so critical so to be
super warm and kind and loving in those
is builds really great rapport if you
don't mind us I'll interrupt you
yes and just like if one of the circling
moves would be to say like how was it to
hear what Sean said yeah yeah that's
good and what that does is like brings
it now into either like the kind of
second person or the first person
instead of which I'm doing now
unfortunately it's like talking about a
third person perspective of what's
occurring mm-hmm so I do actually wonder
how that's good is to hear what Sean
yeah this is such a cool part of
circling is to be able to stop and then
say how did that make you feel when he
said those words yeah I like that a lot
and I just want to say before you do
like you did ask me about how I was
feeling yes yes so I'm ready to answer
that as well okay yeah okay so on it
feels good it feels like how often out
of 400 people do does someone actually
slow down and say that wow that was so
warm and it's extended itself to even
until now and then the directedness so
there's it's kind of you get to both of
those adjectives have power in different
ways and so it'll take a while to even
be able to understand how those can like
live together and interplay with each
other in social dynamics so we can maybe
look at some of that in a bit yes this
god deeper layer it's like how the
warmth impacts me is not only do I feel
like some a little safer now without
realizing it like I'm not kind of guy
that walks around like
wondering if I'm safe I'm late we heard
that not my usual identity but but I
just noticed just now is it also makes
me feel safer that we you might want to
hang out again in the future which is
also another kind of late relaxation
because it seems like the power or the
intelligence of your warmth
kind of has that impact on me
what happens now you take a deep breath
yeah it's like good and it's it's it's
nice to to feel that there's a desire to
want to partake in more of this
exploration together that feels really
good and it's mutual and yeah so let's
let's speak on that this one year that's
been on the heaviness is what is this
heaviness is that yeah from it's been a
it's been a humbling year for me
and I think there are a lot of ways in
which I was like man we've got this
transformational connection modality
it's unique it's different cutting-edge
and like I kind of thought we were
awesome or like the best at everything
and I still think we're the best I'd
like one thing or a couple things but
but I just got shown in many different
ways like all the places I'm very
immature unprepared whoa I almost want
to cry hate talking about it and I could
be more specific some of the stuff I
imagine like it's stuff that everyone's
going through with social media being
maybe you experience this being a kind
of like a white male and a kind of
position of power getting a lot of
challenge for that and it's even that
was humbling in ways where I thought you
know
oh well that's silly blah blah blah and
then I'm like well actually that that
was right for various reasons I wasn't
aware of
whoa okay so take take me into the well
first one you said all that I realize
that I can also open up and say that a
lot of transformative experiences have
happened in a somewhat similar way
potentially for me and then another
thing was wanting to hear you explain
more about what the experiences have
been like for you and you slowly gave us
a couple but I'd love to hear more yeah
another one is with social media which
again I think a lot of people are
starting to experience a kind of souring
in a way of and it's really pertinent to
this kind of relational methodologies
we're talking about because it of the I
think that the online forums are not
really great for building connections
but we found I mean even this practice
community that we've cultivated of
people really doing their best to be
honest and empathetic and and really
kind of go the extra mile and in in
being what feeling what it's like to be
with somebody else the conversations
online would get very nasty very fast
and and it it was just totally
overwhelming like in our Facebook groups
and people would come in that had never
done the practice before or not with us
and start criticizing our method which
often wouldn't even align at all but
then it's it was scary it was just like
even even though like my best days I'm
like I have this stoic philosophy of
like being indifferent to the forces of
indifference which is pretty much
everything outside of my perception it
still was like terrifying like oh my
gosh is this like this is gonna affect
our business or like are they right
about stuff that I'm not seeing and I
can feel the kind of panic even like
calling that into mind like right now
and maybe you can speak to your versions
excited I didn't know we were gonna go
yes please do you have some somewhat
similar thoughts well yeah I can
definitely feel some of the tension and
I can give a little metaphor it was a
bit late we were late in matrix 1 mode
so we'd like escape the matrix we found
this like new way to relate it was like
transforming us it was like a lot of
people having deep experiences we're
like man misses and then you get into
matrix 2 and you realize well you've
escaped the apparent matrix but now
you're in an even more complicated and
dark difficult world which is like way
more difficult than you ever imagined
and test you on a deeper level okay let
me let me see here so the first escape
is to just realize that there's
something beyond the economic social
political machinery that we live in and
and you're like your own mind like the
matrix is like a simulated reality so
there's a way we we have our experience
it's very built by layers of like
beliefs and emotions and like worldviews
have come from a whole life and like
most unless you've really practiced and
done a practices its effective at like
knowing you're unconscious or
subconscious you don't really have any
idea you see it in the matrix so when
you find a way to like come out and we
were like we've hit the jackpot now not
only can we do this which is usually the
domain of therapy and meditation we can
actually do it by like being in
connection with us and building our
connection yes yes and it doesn't feel
like we're going to like do this secret
process in a therapist room which is
like with people we love yes and it's a
win-win it's fun actually it comes
exciting journey it's the hero's quest
so we're just like we hit the jackpot is
like amazing we're having this like
transformational life we could do it
anywhere in the Train
yeah and whatever you know on a plane
with some random person that you're just
talking to suddenly it's like this very
deep thing where you're having an
insight after inside they're like wow I
haven't had this kind of conversation in
years or ever what do you do yeah and
having mystical experiences like in
connection which normally are only after
some very hard meditation after 10 days
you might luckily get a glimpse but we
were just like popping open so these so
this was like that but in all that
excitement and all that opening there
were places where we yeah we weren't
mature or we weren't really seeing like
the challenges some people faced in
going deeper and being on a journey so
like there were places we were missing
stuff and like the universe is so
generous that it will show us just what
we need to see yeah so we really got
some big like insights and it was like a
painful process of like became what like
we're not just going to like break out
the matrix and everything's fine like
there's a new level to play out now yes
and so we that was humbling and and so
that's where we started to go deeper
into like you know developmental trauma
work and get trained deeply in there
that's where we got like new new mentors
we worked deeply without the yeah we
brought our team together when we
brought in that the women we worked not
just women and men we most trusted to
come in to our team more intimately and
we invested in that so we could work
together more intimately and yeah to
face the world and they've that they've
brought in a whole new dimension to like
you know how we work together and it's
not for the faint-hearted yeah because
they really show up with us smile yeah
is there so much - yeah I think it's
super important to explain
so the normal potentially everyday way
of just cognizing there's potentially
something there is something deeper than
that the subconscious the unconscious
whatever is existing that is part of our
worldview that has been developed in
ways that we may not be very familiar
yeah with and so to take sort of a meta
perspective on that just like you did a
moment ago saying wait how did that make
you feel when he said that which those
words are usually not even commonplace
in conversation so and then so tapping
into self-awareness tapping into what is
let's say graduating from this first
level of the the unleashing unlocking
oneself from maybe the straps that hold
them in the normal machinery of the
world and have at least somewhat of a
meta perspective on the way they behave
they relate with other people okay so
the mad to things to your paraphrase I
think we really helps for the use of
years so like most people at this point
have some sense of like oh yeah there's
these subterranean kind of mashin
nations that are happening in my own
being and I can kind of bring them to
the surface and it gives me new insight
frees up energy what's less common is
they're actually doing that in a in a
kind of relationship so in our we
there's like subterranean stuff you like
happening yeah are we can bring into our
like that species consciousness that's a
good way to put it the subterranean
stuff yes okay so in basically every
time people relate with each other
there's always interesting subterranean
stuff that almost certainly gets
completely avoided into conversation and
so then one of the rules is to be able
to when you relate to try and get to
subterranean stuff and put that up to
the surface and make that fun to play
with yeah yeah that there's a way I like
to like describe that because I remember
like early in my journey the thought of
there being like subterranean stuff of
me was terrified
like even though it's like gung-ho to
let go as deep as I can and learn
everything and but actually I was
terrified and actually what I'm learning
the more and more I kind of refined my
practice is it's actually like there's
like more subtle frequencies to our
experience so actually what we're doing
by circling and connecting is it's a
real strong place where our attention is
like usually directing and moving around
and but we can start to cultivate and
like a deeper subtlety
so like when Jordan saw you like respond
to my share like this showing the warmth
I felt being with you he noticed that
maybe he just like went a little bit to
the side or was like talking
third-person mmm it's like oh what
happened there yeah and then by you like
turning towards which you did you get to
feel a frequency that you normally turn
away from before you even knew it mm-hmm
but now it's like you're turning towards
it not like which is building your
awareness bringing more energy into your
experience which is normally
subterranean but also it's like helping
you relate with me from deeper mm-hmm so
that's what yeah that's what we're
always looking for in the practice so
there's this potentially a micro
awareness that that we have to get good
at catching and then catch how we feel
about something that's happening and
then that's a thing I want to add for
the listeners is like your watchers or
both you whoever I'm pointing at right
now
it's like it's not just like what you
feel is a really good way in but but
actually like what was what might be
interesting is is where your awareness
goes like oh my awareness went somewhere
else what might be interesting is what
what you start to think about and so I
tend to ask more like how was how was
that for you what's the impact
what are you experiencing yeah what am i
noticing now and they're like a little
bit more inclusive because then
yeah a lot of time like it may be that
I'm actually what I'm noticing is I
don't feel anything and that's what's
most interesting is if somebody said
something really deep and powerful and
appreciate it and I'm like I got I'm
empty that's fascinating what's at it
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah I have a lot of
appreciation for how you dive deeper
into the psyche than what is you know
normal at even the what we think is you
get to the subterranean levels of
conversation but really you can go even
more nuanced and even more subtle and I
like how you both do that a lot
I just wanna one of the things one of
the things that you said earlier that
has just been I have to say it it's been
so why it's been now sitting too long is
that this or maybe just right it's it
was when you were both explaining how
you had it humbling experiences getting
from this first level to the second
level and surrounding yourself with
different people that are helping you
grow more effectively and you're
learning a lot more from them you think
maybe you know something about something
that someone who increases your
awareness and you're like crap I didn't
actually know that so I've had a lot of
that too in the last yeah yeah and last
year so it's been it's been great and
actually I've also had those experiences
where I'm like crying about how stupid
[Laughter]
it's funny because it's also when you
have do you have to treat it like it's a
leveling up process and yeah yeah
I feel so much like it's like with you
tenderness and then my own kind of
embarrassment at like my own ignorance
and yeah yeah I want to be tender with
myself the same way I'm with you so I
don't want to okay I can feel like some
part of me wants to call me myself names
you know like yeah yeah good to some of
those names are correct for me at least
when I do call myself then I'm like well
isn't that kind of true isn't that how I
want isn't it how I'm trying to grow to
not behave that way anymore yeah yeah
okay that will say can get interesting
but I'm just wondering like to go
another layer but well it's late even
out drive to grow and to like be honest
and humble ourselves also gets
interesting with more like focus or more
allowing and sometimes it's actually
also a way to manage the sensation or to
manage like what's challenging so we've
actually found a way to like navigate
life by I'm gonna grow as deeper or as
high as I can I'm going to meditate more
I'm gonna I'm gonna be honest and but
even that drive actually has more soil
tea and this has been a big one for me
because I in that drive there's a lot of
fear it's a lot of vulnerability mm-hmm
there's a lot of if I don't grow I don't
want to know what that is yeah and it's
like but actually as they like lean in
and not automatically go towards the
light I'm going to meditate more and do
all the like read the ten books I put by
my bed and all the practice practices I
do if I just feel that drive
actually there's a lot of energy in it
and what if also found is as I felt that
energy and some of the pain and
vulnerability there actually a deeper
self-love emerged or an ease on myself
to like you know relax the driven as'
relaxed this self actualizing like I've
got to do this before I die
energy mmm and actually also a
discipline emerge from that that was
more natural ironically but hmm
this is discipline that arose that felt
more natural what speak to that more
well it's just things like I used to
always have this idea like so if I
meditate in the morning it's like it's
gonna be you know I'm gonna like I'll
wake up in like you know even if it's in
ten years I'm willing to dedicate and
then it was like oh yeah but I also like
know that if I like do movement and like
that's also going to help my expression
and my life force oh yeah and if I
circle and do like trauma therapy I'm
also gonna like open up but suddenly I'm
like it's getting bigger and bigger and
if I read philosophy and I and it's all
exciting stuff but in the end it's like
going to exhaust me so like when I let
go but as I've let go more and felt like
actually like life's evolving me nicely
as it is or like some of that drive is
relaxed and then it just seems like oh
yeah I actually love to meditate
but like only this amount or I can do it
this amount and when I do it there's
less pressure on me so it's actually
like quite relaxed it's more relaxing in
a way I didn't realize before and things
like I just wake up in the morning now
and I go to the park and I just move and
explore it's not so rigid yeah but
actually I probably do more than I ever
did because it's yes more in flow yeah
so yeah that's some of the things I've
discovered so it's as though there's
certain tools that you've added to your
tool belt over time and instead of like
saying I'm gonna use one tool for ten
minutes another tool for 10 minutes it's
just like I know my tools I'm just gonna
go with the flow of which tools I want
to use when yeah and sometimes it's
clear to me like I'm writing writing a
book at the moment on surrendered
leadership so there are times where I'm
like I'm gonna write now for three hours
and I'll pretty much do that
most days so this is still a place where
it feels true to me but yeah that
there's a listening always that has been
cultivated from practicing a
hmm
I'm enjoying like basically being in an
altered state right now just from
noticing my experience like very closely
being with us here
do you feel anything like kind of floaty
or yeah yeah whoo yeah and if you notice
the silence at first it can be late
awkward or late but if you actually
start to listen yeah
it's fun to notice like we get on to do
it like in a talk and actually the most
powerful thing I could possibly say is
silence
I don't know about the most and possibly
that was a bit of hyperbole
I tend to agree that there's always a
lot of filling the space with thoughts
and to slow it down and enjoy the
silence in between and Express how to
other people that that the silence in
between is actually
outstanding in its own ways yeah
there's something about the heaviness
that we were all talking about at the
very beginning that's still subterranean
that still feels like it hasn't been
brought up in its fullest and it would
be interesting to see if we could
somehow bring it up what do we feel
about it do we how do we feel about what
we're going through as we keep leveling
up and having harder challenges that we
face I can can say that a thing of being
subtly noticing it the whole way through
the talk but as you ask me now it's even
clearer that it's like a pain I'm
feeling my solar plexus
so this is one way I'm tracking that and
trying to allow space for that and this
also lists like background sadness
and layers oh Lola and it's like almost
like shame as well
yeah
so imagine that's like part of late
facing some of the challenges they've
had and feeling the pain of like my own
shortcomings and limitations but also
maybe some of the in justices I've faced
and
and even when I say in Justices I don't
know for sure
it's a complex thing to say but your
eyebrows went up that's like double
click on that I like using that double
clicking into that yeah
zoom me out - mm-hmm
yeah
hmm
some background sadness some in Justices
maybe that has something to do with how
people come in and and maybe without
knowing about what the processes are
just immediately saying something about
them of circling but at the same time
like you said I think it's great to also
have an open-minded ear to what is being
said and I have learned quite a bit from
that just keeping an open mind to
critique and growth from that in the
less I mean I I feel I can feel the part
of it it's still like it kind of like
yeah yeah you know I want life to be
comfortable and like easy but but
overall I'm like I'm grateful I think
I'm more grounded and more honest and it
seems like it ironically allows me to be
like the way I think growth actually
works as we deepen in two sides of the
same so like as I get more structured or
capable of structuring I can also bring
more chaos or like more calmness or
still this I cultivate the more I can
also like on a dime like bring anger or
something like that and then let it go
so it yeah it seems like I don't
remember where I was going with that
this is a very complicated process what
we're doing right now it's as simple as
just saying that we're just having a
conversation but we're trying to
purposely do way more than just that
we're trying to get to subterranean
subconscious the microbe feelings that
change where our attention goes
yeah asking you guys a deeper question
about how you feel about what you just
said how that made me feel paraphrasing
what you say in order to make you feel
like I heard you there's all this
complexity that this type of
conversation gets to and it requires a
degree of of mastery also to fall at
work to work on building mastery in this
domain is one of the best domains to
build mastery in because you learn how
to have better communication
transformative communication or
transformative relationships yeah
remember there's great examples of
someone you know saying blah blah blah
blah blah and then like something really
profoundly like sad or something and
then they just keep talking like they
didn't say anything and then that type
of a of a moment to me is like stop what
you just said something about a deep
trauma of your life and you just like
kept talking like you didn't even say it
mm-hmm so keep like what was that tell
us about that whether I think the white
why it's so challenging is like a deeper
pain or actual marrow whatever we call
it say to open to that's not something
small like yeah it changes the whole
experience it's like we might find out
that we've been like
lying to ourselves or tricking ourselves
I don't even like those words but we've
had to defend something protect
something and so we were perceiving
things distorted so that's pretty hard
to see like maybe a lot of decisions a
lot of important relationships have
broke down like on seeing that you see
like why and and also it changes your
whole like narrative structure like
suddenly you've got nothing comfortable
to sit on and like maybe like maybe
you've like cause people pain or your
self pain on a much wider scope than you
ever imagined and that's the kind of
questions that come up when you go into
a new territory mm-hmm so that's why we
that's why we'd like so keen on the
relationships because when you've got a
lot of transformational relationships
around you they can help help you if you
go into that kind of chaos but if you've
not had training in it yes it's like
when I was first starting I was so
defensive and I was not able to say that
it was would have been humiliating for
me to tell you I was defensive so you
might be trying to show that I wasn't in
your kind of ways I mean just because
I've had so many reflections and I've
seen myself defend and then I've seen
people I've challenged and support at
the same time enabled me to have enough
space to like show it and then feel that
oh I'm defending because I'm scared that
you might leave me if I'm not strong
mm-hmm you know to find something like
that so all right
okay so
I'm actually scared I'm gonna be shown
is wrong because I really want people to
stay close to me that I care about
mm-hmm so I've had this whole strategy
without realizing it
that's quite humbling yes so we almost
defend the subterranean processes world
parts of our worldview that we may not
want to bring to the surface yeah defend
them subconsciously yeah and then when
we do it takes a decent amount of of
love play compassion to make space and
time for people to want to do
subterranean dives and just one quick
quick that that we ever think we've
discovered because of this like circling
very purposely doesn't have like this
elaborate model of like how people's
emotions work and how to they deal with
trauma and hmm we use as many maps as we
can in our kind of research but the
practice is more like a paying attention
and entrusting just what's here you know
trusting together like Ascenta cailli to
feel what's here and it will guide us
from the inside and what we found doing
that is actually like say someone is
deeply guarded or defended that the
intelligence of that defending is
actually way more intelligent than we
actually realize so actually the more we
see that it's like you want to actually
trust it so we're not like going in
there to like sledgehammer in a defense
we're like what I know it's that you
know it's right here that you you seem
to pull back yeah yeah yeah what's
happening there like
because it's like guiding us into
intimacy actually currently off Tanvir
like nowhere i contract that's the
problem if I could only not contract
then I would feel more energy with my
lover or but it's actually no the
contractions guiding you and them to
like what's really happening and what's
really meaningful and precious for you
yeah that's great and this is the art
that develops over time of this powerful
intimacy and conversation that is not
you sledgehammer going into to try and
beat the things in the subterranean that
we don't want but rather but gently call
them call them up and and interplay and
deeply learn from from them yeah oh
maybe you would like to say a little
about the like when we're talking about
a transformational communication it's
kind of like from whatever it is now
into what and I I have us like I had
this really clear memory of a friend
coming over and me didn't do any sort of
circling or whatever and I expressed
like oh she said something else like oh
I just feel real sad and she started to
apologize and I'll say oh no like I
really love feeling this it's quite a
gift Wow yeah that's great that's a good
one when people apologize for like when
you may feel a certain way and they're
I'm so sorry you feel that way it's like
know what's yeah okay yeah and there's a
sense of like life like the kind of just
a regular experience of life being
precious and
and those hard those hard things being
like worthwhile on their own yeah and I
think what we what we're moving towards
it's like the kind of gentleness you're
talking about like towards yourself like
it's actually like life this is a
transformative process and like sounds
kind of dumb to say because of course
like when you look at it you're like oh
yeah like in constant change yes but
then the real work is like it's not like
I have to always be like figuring out
what's going on or like that's why we
don't need these complicated models it's
more like can i basically accept the the
movement that's already occurring and in
a way can I get out of the way or or
just kind of align with that yeah that
thing that's already moving me into more
elegance
can i align with
of most spiritual actualization of
myself and see it from a meta
perspective of my behaviors on a daily
basis and the relationships the
communication that I have with people
and it doesn't mean it's like it may be
opening to a lot more sadness like that
but yeah but from a place where it is a
gift yes I mean it's all like happiness
or joy or whatever but there is a kind
of attitude of of alignment or kind of
walking hand in hand with life rather
than like fighting it every step of the
way so when we do maybe feel one of the
vicissitudes of life go on a downs on a
downswing we may be like why do I feel
this way right now maybe I should just
you know tap into the way that I feel
and just kind of like be with the
feeling of that then this may be where
there's potentially a little bit of
pushback where if you just take your
next couple hours if not days to just
focus on this downswing sometimes we
just need to align ourselves back with
our higher purpose and realize that well
me engaging back with what I find to be
most meaningful on a daily basis will
slowly but surely give me not feeling
what I was feeling and back on an
upswing so we can almost
decrease the amount of time that it
takes for us to sort the pendulum to
swing back yeah I think for me that if I
had an idea that if I'm on a downswing
then I should like stop everything and
like just just feel I think actually I'm
already interrupting quite strongly so
if I'm on a downswing and I feel in and
I include my vision and my higher
intelligence I include like what I what
I just want to do anyway like I might
want to go and play sports or just have
it's like I'm including all the
information and it might be on a
downswing that I'm actually drawn to
take more action that might be actually
what's being called for I don't know it
but it's sometimes it might be in there
yeah there's something that I really
need time to you know and then I can
like yeah take the time to feel this
important distinction yeah
I wonder if we talked about like going
into some of the push like the pushback
that you or someone maybe you've heard
or viewers have said about like well
this from previous episodes like
circling sounds like this would be dumb
because of XYZ I wonder if there's more
that we can just be do directly or like
maybe we agree with them or like oh yeah
that was a mistake we've made over and
over again that now we've you know
hopefully corrected or working on it or
something I just want to invite the kind
of directness if it's there well I think
what we were just talking about a moment
ago is it was kind of spot-on is that
when is when we feel the Bhoomi kids
happen to the pendulum swinging
potentially on its on its downswing and
we just we say maybe I need to put
everything away in just lay down on the
ground and just be right and like cool I
agree that that can tapping into that
can actually be creatively powerful at
times too at the same time there's the
well could i potentially swing myself
back into a flow state right now doing
what i so yes maybe stuff like that
another thing is just that just that
sometimes when it's don't it almost
seems as though we need like there have
been instances of people coming back to
circling and coming back to circling and
me circling in some ways is kind of like
a like you come in you learn how to get
better at the art of transformative
communication and connection and then
yes you continue practicing it but you
potentially practice it back in the
thing that you were doing in the
community that you were in and what not
and you sparking other things sometimes
it can be that someone comes in and is
just like it's potentially just
- maybe deprived of touch or love or
compassion or people to actually care
yeah listen
and I think circling does a great job at
at providing space for for subterranean
thoughts to come up I think that's very
beautiful so it's kind of adjust to just
trying to figure out where to exactly
come in for how long how exactly when do
i how do I take some of the things I
learned back and apply them to things
like that
so is it like just like one of the maybe
critiques Beco it seems like some people
get into this kind of almost like
navel-gazing
like we're just gonna keep doing this
thing and they never actually take this
the growth and like bring it out to
their community or their jobs or their
families they just kind of seem to keep
trying to get some other need met in
this practice rather than so pop partly
if there is still a need that needs to
be met go for continued you know seeing
what needs can be met at the same time I
talked a lot about we live in a physical
three-dimensional world and if we want
to take some of the old code that lives
in the world and update it with new code
we really need to build new mental maps
and new systems that obsolete the old
stuff and to bring the new systems in
and so I feel as though sometimes and
this isn't just true of circling but
it's true of people just hanging out and
philosophizing about things totally
there's so many ways of yeah of of that
it's fine there's a different colors on
a color wheel maybe some people are the
color green and they just want to
philosophize but maybe some people are
the color purple and purple maybe wants
to learn and then go and apply in the 3d
world to inspire other people or build
the things that obsolete the old ones
and we need some action like that too so
anyway that's maybe one of the
but but overall though the this this
attention and awareness that we're
bringing to what is normally just a
conversation but going a little bit
deeper I feel like we do that in some
ways on the show specially we ask people
about their journeys and what led them
to where they got to today because then
you hear things like it was that one
time that someone said that hey go to
that camp go check that out and then
they did and then it did the next 15
years their life were changed and they
kept doors kept opening type thing so
yeah so that that type of stuff is
important to get to although a lot of
what we do on the show is very
intellectually driven stuff well we
talked to today and yesterday vegan
stuff we talked a lot about spirituality
and modern masculinity and stuff like
that and that was very interesting it
kind of obviously took things on a
different angle than deep biotech or
neuro tech or blockchain or AI so and
that's one of the benefits of doing
multidisciplinary stuff so they sync
that's like two things because there's
the original like this is some of
they're like maybe challenges someone
might have of the practice and what this
is like there's another part you're
going into wonder if like we address the
first one or like yeah because because
actually I just picked up this mug in it
and like I can I think the first one is
is a is a big potential issue I I'm not
very inspired to lead a practice where
people are just staying around with each
other only doing philosophizing or only
doing like talking about their feelings
over and over again like I am super
inspired by a world the world that we
live in like being more meaning filled
more connected more alive like
more capable than actually being with
people and so I just thought of two
really important examples with this is
happening one is like this this mug who
will teach robots ethics I think it's
perfect because we've been working with
some a lot of people involved in AI and
AI risk and a safety and it's like this
is one of the questions it's very very
difficult to answer so it's it's like
one is like circling is like okay what
actually we don't even know what our own
ethics really are and how we compose
them and how they develop and there's
all sorts of theories but like we can't
formalize that into mathematics so
that's one thing is like getting clearer
because ethics is really an inter
subjective thing right it's well there's
a lot we could talk about but it seems
okay at least can includes like an inner
subjective component but but although
also like we're using circling in those
conversations so like I was at a retreat
or I was leading a retreat recently
where there's a category theorist you
know from MIT talking with the
consequentialist philosopher about this
problem and then what would happen is
they'd stop mid-conversation back wait
hold on what you just said that made
sense with all the language of it but I
noticed I was just totally empty inside
and I like my mind started wandering
like that's great can you know you know
could you say that again or could you
say it a different way so using the
tools to like have a conversation and it
really grounded way you can dive into
subjects like the complexity of of AI
ethics and risk mitigation by having a
better tool belt of knowing how to have
transformative communication and
connection between people to where you
can feel okay with saying that whoa what
you just said I don't think I I didn't
catch that I want to be able to catch
that let's go back visit it there's tons
of good stuff like that
yeah and we yeah we work in business as
well and the same things happening there
like someone's like doesn't realize that
they you know can't feel their anger or
they fear their anger which they learn
very early on so every time they're in a
meeting
they're late like passively aggressively
or under the surface like giving a lot
of quite vicious anger but they look
completely calm and to them they feel
calm but it's having like devastating
effects on the people in the business
but they also have things around anger
so they they don't really know what's
happening they just think they don't
like them and so that's just like
running the company and actually late on
deeper exploration his angers maybe like
completely aligned with like the higher
mission of the organization so if there
was less fear he would be like a huge
driving force and actually all the other
people if they like could receive anger
they and feel their own that could like
boost like the whole not just the
connection but the energy of the whole
organization so there are ways we can
apply and also for us that when we
develop circling me and John who
co-founded the company we did it in a
tennis academy an elite sports academy
so that was our playground so we were
always like what's effective for the
athletes jon kyl yes a different Jersey
for John different Johnson okay yeah
good good clarification yes we would we
were finding the methods the most would
impact the the athletes and we found off
often the relationships with the parents
are very important so we were always
geared towards like what actually work
that was always a grounding and then
we've all been very diligent like in our
relationships and like you know not just
in the organization in the practice but
my fiance my family yeah in the grocery
store right how I relate to animals like
yes everything becomes an arena of
practice of practice correct of being in
a state yeah
Connect I just want a cup just a couple
thoughts what one of the things that I
want just at the very beginning we were
talking about how there's a big process
of self-awareness of knowing thyself and
and being able to dig into these
subterranean thoughts about oneself and
how we even engage with the reality that
we live in how we engage with other
people how we can look at ourselves in
the mirror and really work on ourselves
these are some of the core ideas of what
we I think can unpack more in I want you
know more often to have conversations
like this in the studio where we can
just dive deeper into the subterranean
areas without talking about what we oh
well you're also building this thing in
yeah this air this field and they are at
the edge of the field and so that's
versus you know diving deep into em yeah
so I would like to you know plant a flag
in in this being potentially acting as a
megaphone for more of the conversations
around this subject and we can dive
deeper into them on an on a following
because there's so much to understand
about the methodology of relationships a
transformational communication in
general and what it means for different
worldviews to be engaging with each
other in general yeah it's it's a very
exciting topic and there's so much
nuance
so so let's we're probably yeah time is
we're there Ronnie Ronnie Vargas that's
right
cool so
what is it like to be you right now
I feel like flushed it's like I have so
much I'd love to say
um
like noticing how much I enjoy attention
and feeling self-conscious about it it's
like then wanting to include you guys to
like mitigate the pressure of admitting
that
if ya feel a lot of enthusiasm feel like
yeah there's a lot deeper we can go I
love I love the depth I also love the
like visioning as well I think yeah that
flows cool for me mm-hm
enjoyed being here with you feel like
I'm getting to feel your vision and
unique way of enacting it and likewise
yeah yeah this was really nice and it
was good that we had this up for a
second time with Jordan for the first
time with Sean thank you cool thank you
for coming yeah thank you for coming
thank you thank you the super pleasure
that was so nice and thank you Ron for
producing and directing we love you very
much
I love you too Alan and you love sushi I
know I know that sushi I love my disco
shoes
Shawn you're handsome bastard you know I
gotta say that they both do it yeah
Jordan yeah that was bullseye into my
shyness good shot I love it I love it
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode for those that notice that the
intro was slightly different than what
we normally do we can check out both
Jordan and Shawn's link in the bio below
about the transformational communication
practice that they run called circling
Europe it's circling Europe calm they're
online every day circling a circle
anywhere calm and they're surrendered
leadership practices surrender
leadership calm so go and check them out
and support the artists the
entrepreneurs and the organizations
around the world that you believe in
sports simulation our links are below so
we can keep doing cool things like
scaling our impact and building this up
go and build the future everyone share
content like this day keeper into the
nuance of transformational connection
and communication share with your
friends and family or coworkers online
on social media thank you very much for
tuning and we love you very much and we
will see you soon
[Music]